So the final change we're going to make, is thinking about our
random surfer model. If this was our model, if a page has
no incoming links, well, it's popularity ranking would be 0. We
don't want to have that be the case. If we think of
our random web surfer, well if she randomly starts at a
page, she could randomly start at a page that has no links.
If we made all the page scores 0, for pages with no
links, well, then it would be very hard for a new page
to get started. So, we don't want those to be 0,
so we're going to have some random probability that you reach a
page even when it has no links. So that means we're going to
add something to this sum so it's not zero when there are
no incoming links. And the other thing we're going to do
is we're going to scale this summation a little bit. And we're
going to scale that with what is called the damping function. And
that just means, if we think of our random web surfer again,
even if she's following a path. That does have more
links. At some point, she might decide to get tired and
give up and start again with a new random page. So,
the dampening function determines how frequently, we think our random web
surfer will pick a random link, versus starting over again
on a new random page. So that's call the dampening value
and we are just going to use the dampening value to scale
this number. So, we'll call that d, that's the dampening constant.
A typical value for that is something less than one,
and a good value is something like 0.8. So now we're
going to change our rank function to take into account that. We're
going to have some initial value and if we want to keep the
values in a reasonable range, instead of starting from one,
we're going to divide the values by a total number of pages.
And the reason for that is just to keep the ranks
in some meaningful range. This will keep the ranks so the
total of the ranks when we start the sum of the
ranks is 1, that gives them a little more meaning then if
the sum of the ranks was the number of pages. So
n is going to be the number of pages, the total number
in our corpus and d is the damping constant, and so
now we're going to change our initial values to divide them by n.
This means, the sum of the paid ranks at the beginning will
be 1, and, we're going to change the way we compute the rank
by adding to it, a value that correspo... That gives
us the sense of starting over. So, the value that we're
going to use for this is 1 minus d, divided by n
and, that gives the notion that. That times when we don't
decide to do a new page. So, 0.8 of the
time. We decide to follow a new page. So we're going to
multiply this by D. The times when we don't follow a
new page, that's one minus D. We're going to start over, and
we're going to divide that by N, because N is the
number of pages that the probability that this is the page
that would be picked when we start over. So now we've
got our recursive definition of page rank. We start by initializing
the rank n times at 0 to one minus, divided by
N, and then for as many times up, as we want,
we're going to keep improving our results. By using this formula. For
each link that links to us, we're going to take it's popularity
on the last step, divide that by the number of out
links so it's dividing it by the number of other pages it
links to. Multiply that by our damping constant and that gives
the probability that this page was selected by the random web surfer,
and then we're going to add the term that takes into
account the random web surfer might have started over from scratch and
picked a new random page. So, before we try to change
our Web search engine to actually program this, it's time for a
little quiz. And the quiz is, What is AltaVista? And if you don't know this,
feel free to use Google, or DuckDuckGo, to find out. These are the choices so,
it's the view from the Udacity headquarters
in Palo Alto. It's the most popular web
search engine in 1998. It is Spanish for,
You're Terminated Baby and, it's a small town
in Virginia. And feel free to Google the answer if you don't know.